en este vídeo quiero hablarles acerca de
la expansión del triple producto de
vectores o acerca de la fórmula de
lagrange y realmente no es nada difícil
de plantear el problema lo que me voy a
tomar es el producto cruz de tres
vectores sin embargo reducir esto va a
ser todo un vídeo bastante entretenido
porque al final vamos a llegar a la
expresión de productos puntos que
escalan una diferencia de vectores ya
verás a qué me refiero y es que reducir
del producto cruz a producto punto
realmente es un gran paso porque
recuerda que el producto plus es difícil
de realizar y esto nos ayudará bastante
el producto cruz es pesado de calcular
computacionalmente y al menos en mi
mente es un poco confuso y bueno esto
nos forzó que lo sepas y vas a estar
trabajando con vectores sin embargo es
bastante útil mi motivación para
trabajar este problema en este vídeo es
que había algunos problemas del examen
de ingreso al instituto de tecnología de
la india en el cual esperan que tú sepas
la fórmula de lagrange o la expansión
del triple producto de vectores así que
manos a la obra tenemos primero de cruz
y bueno para esto lo que quiero decirte
es que todos los vectores los voy a ver
de la siguiente manera voy a hablar del
vector
como aquel factor que puede descomponer
como x que multiplica al vector y más
alguien que va a multiplicar al vector j
recuerda que son nuestros vectores
canónicos ya esto le voy a sumar a z que
multiplica al vector canónico que es una
forma de descomponer a amd y así voy a
manejar también a b y así esto va a ser
mucho más fácil que hagamos todas las
cuentas así que primero tomemos ve
crucen y para esto lo que tengo que
hacer es tomarme la definición del
producto cruz y voy a poner aquí quienes
ve cruce explícitamente es decir no voy
a tomar el determinante de quien bueno
primero tenemos que poner a los vectores
canónicos esto simple y sencillamente es
la definición del producto cruz es otra
forma de sacar de una manera rápida el
producto cruz y me queda
jk que son los vectores canónicos y
después ve pero ve es el vector que
tiene como entradas de x b
z recuerda que si estamos tomando todos
los vectores así que vamos a escribirlo
x z y después cruz
entonces abajo voy a poner así c x games
y cct a lo que tenemos que hacer es
tomar el determinante de una matriz de 3
x 3 es decir vamos a fijarnos en la
primera entrada que es y que va a
multiplicar a su vez a quien nos
olvidamos de este renglón y de este
renglón y entonces nos queda belle por
cc tampa bay por 60 ya esto le vamos a
quitar bz por c jeff vamos a poner todas
las veces ves eliminamos todo esto
solamente sacamos el determinante de lo
que está aquí bz por c james perfecto
después nos tomamos la siguiente
componente pero recuerda que hay que
cambiarle el signo vamos alternando los
signos cada vez que tengamos que sacar
el determinante de una matriz y entonces
nos va a quedar nos eliminamos estas dos
columnas y nos queda b x x y z b x por
60 menos y después de que restar de los
otros dos es decir me van a quedar bz y
cx menos bz y c x perfecto y ahora
alternamos los signos ponemos camps y
vamos a sacar lo correspondiente para
acá nos eliminamos estas dos columnas y
nos queda b xl menos wgc x menos b y c x
y entonces ya con esto tengo cuánto vale
explícitamente de cruz cm así que ahora
lo que voy a hacer es calcular lo mismo
pero con amo y está de lujo porque ya
llevamos el primer paso fíjate que esta
forma de escribir el producto cruz se me
hace muy rápida y muy sencilla de
calcular y no hay error ahora vamos a
ver lo mismo con amd y entonces esto
calcular a cruz este resultado que tengo
aquí entonces voy a poner aquí los
vectores canónicos otra vez y jcam y
jota y acá y voy a sacar un determinante
enorme y abajo voy a poner a ese x ayer
y aceta y ahora calcular el determinante
pero para que no nos confundamos
aquí tenemos y j y k y lo voy a borrar
entonces dejen mejor agarrar el color
negro y ahora sí con el color negro voy
a poder borrar
y vámonos voy a borrar esta j
sin embargo ten cuidado porque aquí es
un menos j entonces lo que voy a hacer
es borrar todo en menos j todo este
vector y lo que voy a hacer es alternar
los signos de esto que está aquí adentro
es decir en lugar de poner b x cz menos
bz cx voy a cambiar los signos y poner
esto al revés
bz c x menos b x c c está lo único que
hice fue cambiar los signos y después
voy a borrar también toda esta presión
que tengo aquí para que no nos
confundamos porque si no lo hago van a
salir un buen de errores y es más
déjenme poner un un grosor un poco más
grande para que se borre mucho más
rápido todo esto vamos a borrar borramos
borramos y ahora voy a regresar a mi
punta original al fino de mi punto
original y entonces tengo este último de
aquí y ahora hay que calcular el
producto cruz de todo esto y por lo
tanto hay que sacar el determinante de
todo esto que tenemos aquí ahora bien lo
que voy a hacer explicar no solamente en
la componente x las demás componentes
pasa algo muy parecido a la componente x
por lo tanto si nos tiramos solamente
que es lo que pasa con la componen
x de este vector que nos va a resultar
al hacer este producto cruz vamos a
poder entender qué va a pasar con las
demás componentes porque va a pasar
justo lo mismo es decir para hacer esto
mucho más rápido solamente mo graficar
en la componente y del vector resultante
de este producto cruz así que tomemos el
vector canónico ahí y entonces solamente
me voy a fijar en estos cuatro que están
aquí entonces eliminó estas dos columnas
y me queda allí que multiplica a estos
dos así que de una vez voy a multiplicar
allí por cada uno de estos dos términos
que tengo aquí me queda allí que
multiplica a b x que a su vez multiplica
6 menos pues que multiplica a belle que
su vez multiplica hace x todo esto que a
su vez multiplica hace x y después hay
que restarle la multiplicación de aceta
con estos dos es decir me queda aceptar
por bz porsche x pero negativo porque
recuerda que lo estamos restando a z bz
cx y después menos x menos me da más y
es acepta por el que está aquí abajo
hace está por b x por c c
ya continuación voy a hacer un truco que
me va a servir bastante para poder
encontrar el patrón que se va a formar
aquí que me va a ayudar a encontrar la
fórmula de lagrange lo que voy a hacer
es simple y sencillamente sumar a xv y
xx y también restar a x b x x darse
cuenta que no estoy haciendo nada lo
único que estoy haciendo es sumando una
cantidad y restando esa misma cantidad
menos a x b x c x y es que la utilidad
de este truco es bastante grande ya
habíamos visto varias veces sumar algo y
restar algo es no hacer nada sin embargo
esta pequeña trampa me va a ayudar
bastante a factorizar toda esta
expresión porque a continuación lo que
voy a hacer es fijarme en todo lo que
tenga que ver con b x y factorizar de
ahí lo más que se pueda
fíjate bien me voy a tomar este de aquí
voy a factorizar a b x
de x que multiplica quien bueno lo
primero que quiero que te des cuenta es
que ve x multiplica a este me voy a
fijar también en este y también me voy a
fijar en este en el último no solamente
los que son positivos b x que
multiplicar en primer lugar
porsche y después no es verdad de hecho
lo voy a poner mejor primero con x 9
fijar primero en este componente
entonces me va a quedar b x que
multiplica a x c x para ponerlo todo
ordenado después voy a poner la
componente iría más allá se ve x
multiplica también hay más serie y
después a esto le voy a sumar este de
aquí a ver x también multiplica a zeta
cz a zeta cc está muy bien estos tres ya
los tengo apuntados aquí a continuación
me voy a fijar en todo lo que multiplica
hace x pero no voy a tomar negativo
menos c x que multiplica a quien bueno
si te das cuenta hasta acá al final
tengo c x que multiplica
xb x entonces x b x después c x también
multiplica
y además es negativo por lo tanto vamos
bien a esto lo voy a sumar a y b ye y
después también multiplica a zp z
entonces lo voy a poner positivo porque
ya estoy factor izando el signo y me va
a quedar a zbc está muy bien y lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que quien
tenemos aquí este de aquí todo esto de
aquí si lo observa fijamente te vas a
dar cuenta que es la definición de a
punto set el vector a producto punto con
el vector se es la definición del
producto punto de este vector y este
vector que tengo aquí por lo tanto me
queda a puntos que multiplica a su vez a
b x a la componente x del vector b
entonces esto va a multiplicar a la
componente x del vector b y vamos con
mucha lógica porque acuérdate que
solamente estamos viendo qué es lo que
pasa con la componente x de nuestro
vector resultante y después date cuenta
que todo esto es a punto b el vector a
producto punto con el vector b que
multiplica a su vez a la componente x
vector ce ojo date cuenta que solamente
estamos hablando de la primer componente
por eso tenemos todo multiplicado por el
vector canónico y todo esto está
multiplicado por el vector canónico y lo
que a su vez no está diciendo que es lo
que está pasando solamente en la primer
componente de nuestro vector resultante
ahora bien no voy a trabajar con las
demás componentes sería un buen
ejercicio que tú trabajas con las demás
componentes y te vas a dar cuenta que si
tú realizas las mismas operaciones vas a
llegar al mismo patrón que voy a poner
justo ahorita porque lo que quiero que
veas es que la siguiente componente en
el componente j me quedaría la suma de
todo lo que voy a poner aquí x la
componente j
y se va a cumplir el mismo patrón si
aquí tengo b x voy a tener
beijing y si aquí tengo c x voy a tener
6 james y después multiplicando a la
componente b y me va a quedar apuntó cm
mientras que el otro lado multiplicando
la componentes ella me va a quedar a
punto b y en medio me va a quedar 1 - y
qué creés para la tercer componente o si
vemos todo esto multiplicado ahora por
la componente camps me va a quedar
exactamente lo mismo solamente
con sus respectivas componentes es decir
no va a quedar bz aquí me va a quedar cz
y después nos va a quedar multiplicando
a cc está a punto b apuntó ven y después
aquí me va a quedar a punto sé que va a
multiplicar a la componente vez están
aquí en medio menos y entonces ya te
puedes imaginar lo que viene porque lo
que viene es que podemos nosotros
distribuir la multiplicación de vectores
y jota y cap por cada una de estas
entradas y factorizar y entonces va a
quedar esto mucho más sencillo y bueno
realmente no quiero saltar muchos pasos
pero date cuenta que todo esto después
de distribuir el vector y me va a quedar
el vector b y también para el vector se
es más vamos a hacerlo con calma para
que te des cuenta de qué es lo que estoy
haciendo fíjate bien lo que voy a hacer
es distribuir el vector y por lo tanto
lo voy a tachar de aquí y lo voy a poner
aquí y lo voy a poner también acá lo
mismo voy a hacer para el vector j
entonces cómo se pueden distribuir los
vectores la multiplicación de vectores
es distributiva pues voy a hacer lo
mismo con jota voy a poner j-king ya
jcam y voy a hacer exactamente lo mismo
para acá acá lo voy a distribuir y voy a
poner cada aquí
y acá acá el vector canónico y j y k ya
los distribuye y entonces fíjate bien de
todos estos que tengo yo aquí que me va
a quedar tengo primero puedo sacar con
un factor común apuntó c recuerda que
apuntó que es un escalar y lo puedo
sacar con un factor común que sube es
multiplicar a quien bueno en primer
lugar va a multiplicar a b x que
multiplica el vector canónico y más
vélez que multiplica al vector canónico
jota más bz que multiplica al vector
canónico acá
bz que multiplica el director canónico
camps y mientras del otro lado tengo que
puedo factorizar apuntó ven si te das
cuenta todos tienen apuntó ve y de hecho
es negativo menos apuntó ven que
multiplica a quién
y es que date cuenta de algo todo esto
que tenemos aquí abajo este de aquí es
la definición de ven esto es lo mismo
que el vector b fíjate que tenemos el
vector b y cada uno de sus componentes
por lo tanto aquí va a ser lo mismo para
hacer tengo cx y massey jcct acá que son
los vectores canónicos entonces me queda
mi vector cm y bueno si no me crees que
me salga todo esto sería muy bueno que
tú hicieras todas
para verificar que en efecto estoy
llegando a este mismo resultado porque
ahora sí voy a poner la fórmula de
lagrange o la expansión del triple
productor vectores que me queda a cruz
de cruz cm a cruz de cruce dejemos
ponerlo todo con distintos colores me va
a quedar igual a quien bueno primero me
fijo en el primer vector que está dentro
del paréntesis es decir b me voy a fijar
en el primer vector que está entre los
paréntesis eso es muy importante y lo
voy a escribir en primer lugar es decir
me va a quedar b el vector b que va a
multiplicar a quién dejan ponerlo aquí
ven que multiplica a quien a apunto c 10
que esto es mucho más fácil de calcular
de una manera computacional y es que
seamos la lista es tomar productos
puntos es mucho más fácil que estar
pensando en calcular por los productos
cruz el vector de que multiplica al
escalar a puntos m ya esto le voy a
quitar el segundo vector que está dentro
del paréntesis el vector sem que
multiplica a su vez al escalar a punto b
es decir el producto punto de los otros
dos apuntó b ya que es
y lo hemos logrado aquí está de forma
explícita la fórmula de lagrange es la
expansión del triple producto de
vectores y bueno tal vez toda esta
demostración no es necesario que te
sepas de memoria completamente sin
embargo creo que es bastante útil esta
forma de lagrange cuando tienes poco
tiempo y estás en una competencia o en
un examen de admisión y es que recuerda
que la fórmula es la granxa lo que hace
es reducir te de productos crudos y
productos punto lo cual es mucho más
sencillo